why can't we honestly have an assessment
and come to an agreement by the way i
would have been perfectly comfortable
people said derek chovin was guilty of
manslaughter i'm comfortable with that
charge i'm not comfortable with the lies
that have been told repeatedly about who
this man was if you care about black
lives if you're watching a sneaking
candice i just care about black lives
then why can't we discuss black
criminality at the same time because
usually on the other end of black
criminality is a black victim
that was the case with jacob blake that
was the case over and over again with
george floyd
that's also the case with and let's talk
about the person that was trending all
last night and all this morning makaya
bryant is that her name the woman the
the young woman that they're now saying
a 16 year old girl in columbus ohio who
was shot on tuesday by police
did you guys see the clip of her mother
she was shot and killed by police
because she was attempting to stab
another girl it's on camera she was a
knife wielding maniac but those details
don't matter don't forget because her
mother came out and said that makaya had
a motherly nature about her
she promoted peace mikayam bryant's
mother wants you to know
only you guys see it as normal but it's
still very unnecessary just to be
killing people like in the uk because
not everyone's commissioned to have guns
people just get tasered like you have
people with mental health or people
robbing people and the police will just
come in and just taser you like i think
in america we're very quick just to
start shooting people like not even like
a leg shot or footstool you just start
shooting people like i actually i went
to a police academy school thing because
i used to sell copiers okay and i sold
the copier to this like
yeah like like the big it's the worst
job i've ever had but like like a big
copier like the ones that sit in the
office oh yeah and i sold one to like a
police like it's like um
it was a private police training like
they would hire them to either like
train security guards or police officers
so they're not trained to just shoot you
they're trained like if so if you have
your hands up and you reach then they're
trained to shoot because you like you
could be reaching for a gun and it's
really hard because it's like at such a
quick decision
i got shot every single time they let me
play oh my god i got shout out but why
can't you just obviously this is because
we don't have guns as well actually we
have guns if you're from the from the
end you know or you'd say the hood you
know there's guns everywhere
but we don't have guns already available
so police aren't taught that so it's you
like if you get someone who's knife
wielding like her idea was talking about
makaya right she was knife wielding yeah
that person will just get tased and
you'll get the same if you have free man
tasing you why do you need to shoot that
person
okay because if she's got like a gun on
like on her
neck
but as i'm saying in the uk we have
loads of situations there's loads of
videos i'll show you where they'll just
tase you like bear man get tased
i never i'm just saying like
why do you need to shoot someone because
obviously they've got like because
there's loads of people with mental
health there
who'll be knife wielding in london
there's loads of videos yeah and they
just taste them like why'd you need to
shoot them to me it's like you've lost
all your rights the second you tried to
kill no but that's what but that's when
you're not valuing life in a sense
someone could be a madman if you're a
madman you need to be tased and you need
to be sectioned okay you don't you don't
need to be shocked
yeah if you're my man you are just
killing my people you just need to put
them in a home give them some medication
i don't want to be i don't want to be
the one
you want to go watch them in the home no
you're going to put that out
that's because you don't have to deal
with the problem yeah i pay my taxes
that's what they do
don't you guys have like isn't it hard
to fill jobs here like aren't you guys
yeah well the the us's economy is the
strongest at the moment how many i want
to know how many i'm just curious deaths
by police
happened
in 2021 uk i'm just curious
the fatality
no not shot i said she won in the whole
year and that was probably yeah but
that's that's shot one person i said how
many died yeah people died obviously in
police custody oh see look at it
united states united states i was about
to say
wow
well well why don't they have this
number because not many people are dying
in the uk
there is a ah wait a hundred and ninety
one
police related deaths though that's
different please no that's the same
thing you have to see the ins and outs
how many
people are in the uk
because police rated deaths could be hit
you guys percentage isn't much better
than ours it is you guys because you're
saying that's related
please relate def could be i'm i'm
chasing you and hitting um chasing after
you see road traffic fatalities and you
crash the car oh i see that's not a [ __ ]
i say the police always actually i see
so what i'm just curious how many y'all
got road traffics fatal shootings one 20
and police 20. oh well you guys really
don't
19 in police custody wait 92 plus 50
a apparent suicides following custody
so 92 a hunt so you guys have like a
hundred and i mean if you look death in
police custody but that's actually not
so a hundred so we had a thousand per
year from from 300 something million 329
million you guys had 100 from 67 million
no no but this is where it's different
that was just shootings death in police
custody if you die in police custody you
could have been buzzing on drugs and
overdosing no i just i just took out the
car belgium oh no but death in police
custody that doesn't mean they killed
you you could have just died when you're
there like you died of old age you could
have died from a drug overdose i don't
know that means you died
other deaths durian of following police
contact what contact is that you could
have just he could have arrested you
next day you jump off a bridge like i
need to get a status to her account see
so all we can really go on
i don't think i don't want you to i just
don't think your numbers are that much
better than that no it's one shooting
that's the only definitive one
i don't think i don't think you're
numbers
only one shot i don't think your numbers
are that much faster stories
you just said you believe in guns nah
nah but i believe every if everyone has
everyone should be able to have guns
like the teachers yeah i'm like i'm like
oprah you get a gun oh you could be in
england where no one has a gun and
everyone's cool no i think i think i'd
be like oprah or you can have guns on
the streets right you can have guns for
the streets if you're on the streets you
can have a gun
but you'll probably get some shitty like
little shotgun in that nice rust i'm
like i think everyone should be able to
get whatever gun they want i don't think
so
you don't have stories here for kids
with ar-15 shooting up schools because
that would never work in the you know
how big the us is
you think that would work
shooting up schools they shoot up
schools like for banter
oh my god school shooting this is
another thing they act like school
shootings
us
per year
like
u.s
how many
people died
from school shooting no i'm not dying to
get shots because
because if you do a school shooting or
black 30 only let's say half are going
to die
okay
how about you how many school shootings
u.s 2021
school shootings
how many
34 school shootings all my days death
her injuries 68. that is too mud why is
that they're out of health that's like
that's like not that many uh how many
people how many three hundred how many
people in the uk then
329 million people in the us yeah
how would how would they regulate guns
in this big of a country in a freaking
alaska what are you going to do in
alaska but how many why how many school
shootings in the uk i thought probably
less you guys don't have guns zero but
you guys look at look at uk uk look at
uk map
you're telling me this is
this is what you got you guys are on a
freaking island yeah but we've got zero
see
how many stabbings yeah you guys have
more stabbings yeah we have a lot of
stability to get going
but i'd rather get shot than get stabbed
i will die on this hill nobody's gonna
die
i would rather okay what does it matter
if you're dying yeah because but you're
talking about school shootings people
don't just go and start knifing up
schools
well yeah because they can't shoot as
many people yeah people don't do it okay
okay are there not teenagers that get
knives and stab each other yeah i'm gang
stuff yeah